因为他现在是属于有结婚证的状态，
他给你妈妈转钱的话，
相当于是给婚外第三者转钱，
你妈妈反而变成那个第三者，
你知道吧，
如果他现在合法的妻子想要为你妈妈退钱的话，
你们还得退给他，
我爸妈都是70后，
我妈妈呢是一直是全职在家的，
我爸爸吧，
做生意这么多年下来，
公司的事情，
我妈呢是运营上面基本是不管的，
但是他会有一些钱款，
他的往来就我是去年二五年的上半年吧，
知道他们两个在一几年的时候其实就已经离婚了，
当时离婚的原因是因为我爸爸是搞工程的嘛，
会有一些官司，
为了避免麻烦，
所以当时他们两个是形式上的离婚了吧，
我妈妈也一直是这样认为的啊，
但是昨天的时候我妈妈跟我说，
就是他们两个离婚之后不到一年，
我爸爸就又结婚了，
现在还有一个小孩儿，
那个小孩儿应该只有几岁吧，
我现在的情况是，
虽然我妈妈和我爸爸已经离婚了，
但是他们还在以夫妻名义在对外社交啊，
但是他们没有共同的债务，
是以夫妻名解的，
那我觉得很恐怖的就是这些债务吧，
是我妈妈这边的尊济居多，
我昨天做道这个事情之后，
一直到现在我就在思考这个问题，
我觉得我好像还是不能撕破脸，
我得哄着人把这个钱往回弄一弄，
至少不能把亲戚朋友给坑了，
像一种无从下手的感觉。
我想让我妈把钱往回搞一搞是一方面，
另外一方面就是想保存一下我妈妈名下的东西，
其实这么多年下来的话，
他是搞工。
看了吗？
这两年工程行业也不太好，
我妈妈已经把能卖的东西基本卖差不多了，
他现在名下就只有一套房子了，
还有一个大户还不在他名下，
剩下的就是一些一账的房子，
一账的房子，
现在手续都还没有落实，
能落实的也就是他名下一套房子吧，
还有我名下的车在，
有公司名下的东西，
我想要怎么把这些东西保全，
因为债务人我妈妈是签字了的，
我不知道我担心的有没有道理啊，
我妈妈现在是属于外面的那个嘛，
他跟别人是有法律效力的，
怎么样让钱合法合理的留到我妈妈这儿来，
他不会以夫妻共同名义去追回这个事情，
公司的法人是我妈妈这边的人，
大概就是这样的一个情况吧，
他在外面有家有孩子，
你们是什么时候才知道的，
近期才知道的，
领证儿了，
孩子多大了你们才知道，
五岁左右这个样子吧，
他是一九年领的，
现在是二六年，
大概也就是五六岁这个样子，
那他平时睡觉吃饭，
他在哪个家呀？
三天两头回来他的工地，
有时候会在外地嘛，
经常不在家是一种很正常的状态，
我们也有过嘀咕，
其实我也知道，
就是男人嘛，
就在外面，
你吃喝抽都可以，
你甚至包一个养一个，
这些我都能理解，
但是我没有想到他会做到这种程度，
你妈妈娘家这边亲戚借了多少钱给你爸呀，
大概得有200多吧，
那你妈妈的娘家实力还挺强的，
现在都被他拉下活了。
我爷爷奶奶去世的很早，
从我小时候。
开始在我姥姥姥爷这边长大的，
跟这边亲戚来往也比较多，
我姥姥姥爷可以说是全心全意的帮他，
不过我妈的兄弟姐妹也是这样的，
是这样，
当初你爸和你妈他们两个人在办证件的时候是为了躲债嘛，
那为了躲债的话，
可能大部分的财产是到你妈名下了，
对不对？
嗯，
那既然大部分的财产到你妈名下了，
你妈也卖了很多财产，
那你现在手上有多少钱？
已经没有钱了，
现金基本上已经没有了，
现在是负债的状态，
那你妈妈名下的房产现在还值多少钱？
房产这些年我估计也就几十万吧，
上不了100万吧，
你妈妈自己有工作吗？
我妈妈没有全职在家吗？
当初你们妈妈这边的娘家人借钱给你爸爸的时候，
是你爸爸妈妈都签了字的，
对不对？
有一部分签字了，
有一部分没有钱，
像我姥姥姥爷、
舅舅这些就没有签字，
非常信任他，
就直接拿给他用了，
那你名下的财产值多少钱呢？
我名下我已经结婚了，
你名下没有你爸妈给的财产是吧？
有辆车，
那辆车现在可能也不太值钱了吧，
没有房，
对，
那你爸这个男的真的太不厚道了，
没有江湖规矩，
纯属把你妈妈这边的人当资源用，
那你爸爸现在的财产状况怎么样呢？
他名下也没有东西，
就当时他们两个几乎都转到我跟我妈的名下了，
就是我妈就实心实意跟他过日子嘛，
看他这两年状况不好，
想卖的都卖，
这些年卖掉的还贴补给你爸去做生意了，
是吧？
对，
能卖的都卖了，
他卖房卖车都。
我跟他一起去的，
那现在他在外面结婚生孩子这事儿就是亲戚朋友里面闹开了吗？
都知道吗？
没有，
目前只有我和我妈知道，
所以我没敢在线下这边找律师，
因为我们家这边很小，
圈子很小，
那你们家的亲戚当中有没有那种相对来说社会资源比较丰富的，
他比较打怵的，
害怕的有没有？
没有吧，
我对象在体制里面，
那可能对他构不成什么威胁，
那那这种情况下真的是死局，
他一旦翻脸了之后，
他所有的钱都不还了，
之后他名下又没有财产，
我想了想，
我说我不能撕破脸，
那还得装作不知道，
而就装作不知道呗，
以后如果他要给你妈妈钱的话，
最好是转给你，
因为他现在是属于有结婚证的状态，
他给你妈妈转钱的话，
相当于是给婚外第三者转钱，
你妈妈反而变成那个第三者，
你知道吧，
如果他现在合法的妻子想要问你妈妈退钱的话，
你妈还得退给他，
对，
我也是，
他很搞笑，
对，
所以以后你爸要是转钱的话就给你就得了，
问我妈妈的名下的房子要不要转移一下也可以，
因为这年头比较长了，
他领结婚证算到现在的话都超过五六年了，
因为孩子都5岁了嘛，
那在他领完结婚证这个过程当中，
给你妈妈的所有的转账，
原则上人家那个合法的妻子都可以要回去，
所以你妈妈名下没有财产才是最安全的，
我现在还怕一个问题，
因为他们两个是有一部分是共同签字的债务吗？
家里没关系，
你妈妈名下没有财产，
他就是。
反正他也上黑名单，
怕什么他反正你妈妈也是个家庭主妇，
怕什么做买卖嘛，
现在我能做的就是放在名下的东西转走，
是的，
没错啊，
抓紧时间啊，
让你妈妈名下什么都没有还安全一点，
如果以后要回来钱，
那他回来钱的话，
肯定是项目上回来钱，
回来钱也不要进过我妈的账户，
到我这儿，
不不不，
项目上回来钱的话，
应该是还款，
直接还给亲戚。
还有这样一个情况，
就是他是搞工程的，
他的公司是公司套公司的这种就是公司法人，
很多个小公司，
他们之间也会有这种往来，
但也很乱，
所以说我不知道应该具体朝着哪个方向，
是借款方向，
还是说公司方向，
还是说婚姻方向，
我抓不住重点，
现在他这种干工程的公司之间的往来，
你说法定代表人是你妈妈这边的人，
是说娘家的老人还是什么的，
他的兄弟姐妹，
兄弟姐妹都有正经工作吗？
没有正经工作都是个体，
那基本上都做好心理准备上黑名单吧，
家里的亲戚也会被牵连是吗？
如果他的公司陷入债务危机的话，
作为法定代表人是最终是坐不了飞机，
坐不了高铁的，
所以我现在在想，
都想把这个法人尽快给他转移出去，
那得看你爸配不配合了，
你爸他当初之所以这样安排，
是因为你爸他自己身份有问题吗？
这个公司就已经很多年了，
在他没有问题之前就是这样了，
如果要改的话，
你现在赶紧去改成那种，
家里老人70岁以上。
法定代表人改掉，
如果你爸不愿意改成他的话，
就改成家里的老人，
他现在的状况，
他也是被执行的状态，
他的账户就是被封着了，
家里还有什么老人能顶用的用一下啊，
把年轻人撤出来，
那只能是这样了，
没有什么可以能做的了，
是吗？
能做的只有这一点点都很难。
你爸这个人啊，
城府太深了，
他可以让自己的妻子和女儿在他外面那个家，
孩子都已经5岁了才发现，
可见你爸这个人是你们一般人干不过的，
你们全家人加起来的心眼子都干不过，
我们其实也没太上心，
我前些人就光顾着玩儿了，
我妈妈就是照顾姥姥姥爷，
把两个老人都照顾走了。
我跟你说啊，
但凡你们家有个明白人，
都不会说娘家里里外外给了他200万，
都不会说娘家出兄弟姐妹去给她当法人，
但凡你们家有一个心眼多的，
都不至于这么干，
你们家这么干就是因为一个心眼子的都没有，
一个带心眼子的都没有，
你们怎么干得过你爸干不过他，
我抓紧时间能把这个法定代表人转出去，
就抓紧时间转出去，
转给老人就行了啊，
坐不了飞机就不坐了，
坐不了高铁就不做了，
那所以我现在不能撕破脸把我妈名下东西转出来，
这个公思能甩出去的就甩出去。
对，
我在想，
我想去他那财务，
你说我这样的话挺难的，
如果他真的是财务上有这种各样的，
比如说偷税漏税啊，
比如说财务上有些乱七八糟的账啊，
你去了之后，
可能还有你惹得火上身的，
我不管外面的，
我就管内账。
流如水这种的吗？
我不知道你们当会计的人是不是终身制啊，
当财务当会计的人有没有终身制的这个概念，
如果有终身制的概念的话，
比如说你以后还得靠这个吃晚饭，
靠这个会计啊，
靠这个吃晚饭的话，
你就不能有黑点，
但是他这种做工程的公司没有黑点是不可能的，
对，
嗯，
没很多，
所以我也想不要躺这趟浑水啊，
把你宅得干干净净的才是要紧。
好吧，
我觉得他跟那个女的绝对是在他跟我妈的婚姻情序期间，
酒店开始了，
但是我说如果说现在想要查这个事情就没什么意义了，
是吗？
挺难查呀，
你爸心眼儿那么多，
还能让你们查到蛛丝马迹了，
还能让你们查到他7年前的聊天记录了，
不太可能啊，
你这个不好查，
想追回也没办法，
现在房子别让我妈被追回就可以了，
是吧？
对，
就这意思，
好，
我们明买就是好，
拜拜，
这现实生活人的坏远比电视剧里人都坏还要坏现实生活，
你看这些男的哦，
他还有三天两头还回家呢，
他在外头都跟别人结婚了，
都生小孩儿了，
家里的老婆孩子还不知道呢，
还把家里老婆的娘家的亲戚的200万都给套过去了呢，
还公司里面还用着老婆这边娘家人呢，
刚刚有人说难道不是重婚罪吗？
他这个情况是他先跟这头原配离了，
为什么离呢？
说要逃避债务，
怕这债务影响到你，
先跟你离了，
我跟你离了的话，
我只是离婚，
不离家，
是外人看起来的话，
我俩还两口子过日子。
实际上我俩法律上已经解除关系了，
我在外面再搞一个，
我在结套婚，
我不犯法的，
大家明白吗？
记得点赞关注哦。